But now we come to a robot that
we can demonstrate for you.
It's the PUMA, which stands for
programmable universal machine
for assembly.
In fact, it'll do many
other things as well.
Mr. Hammond is in
complete control.
I hope, and so he'll
now start the robot off.
So that's the starting position.
He has several movements.
That's waist, now shoulder.
As for the right arm,
that's a shoulder movement
as for the left arm.
That's two movements.
That's elbow that makes three.
And then we have free movements
of the wrist, roll, pitch,
and yaw.
So that's the complete
set of movements
with the gripper at the end.
That head can be replaced
by various devices
according to the
job required to do.
Now these are the
single movements.
There's an electric motor
driving each of these joints.
Now we'll show you that
the arm can be coordinated,
so that, like your
own arm, you move
various joints at the same time
to produce certain motions.
And so let's go off with
the coordinated motion
in a straight line.
Called that the x
direction, if you like.
There she goes.
Now we'll do the y direction.
And the z direction.
And then he can
do inclined lines.
I'd better let him
start, I think,
so I know which way
he's going for this.
All the joints,
practically all, are
moving as he follows that trace
and now he's doing that one.
And no doubt will
follow it by that one.
So that's three lines
in different directions.
So now he'll show you something
about reproducibility i.e
getting back to the same
place in succession.
For that, we will apply
that point pointer.
Its gripped.
I will now stand safely back
and watch the proceedings.
That's a point in
space, a marker,
and he's approaching
from behind.
He's now doing a rapid movement
in space, showing off a little
you might say.
And coming back from the top.
Important thing is that he's
getting back to the same place.
He's showing off
again and now he's
coming in again to
exactly the same position.
That's good.
So you can see it
repeats itself,
and it can do these
motions in between.
We take the pointer out
now and invite a challenger
to see if he can beat the
robot at a game, with which I
have to say, the robot
is extremely good.
So do we have a volunteer?
Douglas.
Douglas has, I have to
admit, I tried this before.
Now this is the competition.
Douglas will, in a moment,
point this little curved piece
of wire, and I
switch it on, you can
see that every time
he touches that wire,
it makes a rather
unpleasant noise.
Now your job is
to take it around,
Douglas if you
will, in one hand,
around the wire and
see how far I get
without making funny noises.
Once, doing really well,
thank you, keep going.
Can you just go a little faster?
[BEEPING]
Two.
Three.
[BEEPING]
That's very good.
If we stop at the
top, that's a very,
and you're putting it back, and
we'll switch the machine off.
And I may tell you that that's
not an easy thing to do.
I touched about 20 times
on the first curve.
So Douglas has done
extremely well.
[APPLAUSE]
You notice I switch
the machine off.
Well, we'll start off
by getting the robot
to switch it back on again.
It's on.
[BEEPING]
Oh dear.
That's not very good.
I think it can do better that.
Mr. Hammond is now
telling it to get going.
[BEEPING]
Oh dear.
Couldn't you do something
to it and get it going round
without doing that?
Ah.
Now he's got it going.
So far so good.
That's going to be a clean
run, I think, this time.
Well that's very, very good.
Can it do any better
than that you think?
Watch it showing off at the top.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]